[Music]
in evil twin news Wow very nice mm-hmm
are you an actress uh yeah would you
like to be in the movies sometime soon
is there a couch involved nothing I
wanted a twin so I could use them as my
slave submitted by will you go to prom
with me yes only if you have some kind
of disabilities of them no because I
might be called them alone you will go
to prom for with it with a kid yeah
don't you have to be like a certain age
no if you're a celebrity they can go
with literally anybody somehow they make
it work yeah are you gonna D flow them
like traditional no no wait you could be
Florida boy yeah are you to peel his
banana
nobody wants to have sex with a virgin
cut it out I did if you're military or
if like there's something like molestia
shell weird yes special about you
usually you can get celebrities of your
promise I've seen Oh cuz I've been asked
to go to prom and then I I never got to
go same with you and I and I used to
think it was cool cuz I didn't go to
prom but now I regret it so I want to
relive my prom life I didn't I wanted to
problems dude I'm old man and if I'm
hanging out with this 15 year old girl
they're gonna be like what a pedophile
yeah we should be dates for some other
people and then we get to live out the
prompt yeah then we're not pedophiles
cuz we're like going as a team we have a
prom theme party a lot of girls do don't
they if they do like I didn't get to go
to prom so let's be a bunch of losers in
choppa wake up
you're like falling asleep I love you
calling people losers with the messiest
hair like the fat man the biggest
[ __ ] bunch of bed at Evers
a woman dressed as her twin
a woman dressed as her twin and flirted
with her sister's ex-boyfriend after
killing her it doesn't seem real because
you don't need a dress as your twin you
look like your [ __ ] twin oh no but
the twin has different style though in
this case they do you know if you hang
around twins enough you'll know the
difference you would think so huh yep oh
you know what I never could get over is
like when there's a twin kornel I'm like
how can you [ __ ] your sister it's like
well I'm like oh did you see this one
it's a pretty popular genre it started
in the 80s it's not it's nothing but I
know that it exists and I think your
sister weird well they got to make a
living it's her thing yeah or maybe they
look alike when in one of the playboys
that I got ahold of an elementary school
it was like two naked twins yeah and I'm
like okay we get dresses having sex with
each other
very different no but I was imagining
like the pages moving and stuff and
doing her thing
Oh Natalie accounts Oh after the
disgusting pet like the the disgusting
pervert in me says this is nice but then
the other part is like this is this is
incest this is weird and then the other
part of me is like they should kiss
harder have you ever been watching porn
and yet and you're sitting there right
and it's like you're in your loner and
it's like something happens to the porn
and you're like yeah take it and then
you say it out loud well it got real
quiet that didn't feel comfortable
having in so they caught it that's too
bad all right so this story did you guys
hear about the twins that died in Maui
last yeah from sharks no it's the one of
the twin they were fighting in the car
and fight that's crazy I can't even
imagine that sure we're fighting like
hair-pulling fighting I didn't get over
cliff
this is the crash why does look like the
Ghostbusters car for me Wow
all the wagon yeah these are the twins
so it was a bright it'll look like at
all yeah this is Alexandria and this is
Anastasia Alexandria was the one that
was driving Anastasia was the one that
died did oh she does both they both like
evil twins yeah also so she didn't like
murderers they got is an accident for
like almost died yeah it was pretty much
an actor so she got pulled out with the
helicopter uh what could be crashed
location yeah sure just added a fact
that their bras happen I'm trying to
pull I'm just I'm working on my straw
man arguments okay okay not him just
gave me a bomb-ass idea for a TV show
dude what is it's like right so it's
like two twins right one of them done he
got to see two twins you can just skip
it sounds more like - twins - twins
they're in an accident one of them dies
right one of them because they have this
weird twink twin [ __ ] right how is in
the spirit world one of them is in the
real world they're like [ __ ] solving
mysteries of [ __ ] yeah that's one of
them is linked to this bear world
because they're like dad the other ones
they still have that twin couldn't show
that twin [ __ ] show is either to be on
lifetime or a hundred percent or Niccolo
but money is money my friend that's
right it's a beautiful thing
yeah so they this whole crash happen in
2016 and so Anastasia was jail delighted
to be in prison she just looks so evil
why why she thought it was an accident
well they're not a classifying it as an
axe and they're saying I should killed
her I think that was an accident when
people it's like reckless it's like
reckless driving like a drunk or
whatever with anger who was driving
[ __ ] if your friend you could vouch for
Antwon right like he's Sadiq you're the
twin meld right but what if her sister
pulled her ear and it made her turn yeah
mister move the steering yeah what's the
story about huh she loses a sister and
she goes to jail yes like the Vanilla
Sky moment I don't like the way that
they titled this sister kills sister and
Fleur
with her husband she didn't kill nobody
that wasn't accidental
we're Cameron Diaz she's like I said
I'll get calm and she got a one [ __ ]
turns it or whatever and then he drives
off the things I forgot about that line
[ __ ] that was like one of the
greatest lines I've ever heard like 14 I
swallowed your comes like whoa camera
dear said comer she was in a porno yeah
wait one thing about Mary no Cameron
Diaz before she became big she was made
some money doing some softcore porn Oh
softcore better psyche there's like a
clip floating on the Internet I saw it
not too long ago I can't believe she's a
Mexican yes yeah this is Cuban or
something well it makes it she look
white as [ __ ] he's wider than I am dude
yeah so Alexandria she was charged with
second degree manslaughter
so which but it's a woman though what
woman squats like so true that's just
shows the patriarchy yeah I don't I
don't like that like menstruation issues
every woman straight agency yes the
second degree means that someone died
when it was committed when the defendant
recklessly caused death yes
so if it was burnt a state of Rage yeah
it was first degree and that means like
she intentionally tried to cause serious
harm but I don't know so the point is
she's she's in jail for second-degree
murder and then now the boyfriend of the
twin that died
he's coming out saying that after that
the twin died alexandria put on
Anastasia's clothes started talking and
then they started talking about what
happened and that she avoided all his
questions and that when he saw her in
Anastasia's dress that it was really
disturbing because Anastasia had just
worn that dress a few nights earlier and
then that she started like trying to
cuddle up with him and walls and he knew
was the allergic vaulter mhm yeah one
hiding me oh you know cuz it was like a
big ol accident well maybe she's coping
because she's used to doing everything
synchronized and then she does she lost
her over there half so then now she
needs to fill the void just putting on
her clothes yep I don't blame her I
think it's cool if I was if I was her
husband and I lost and I was like oh boy
your sister's pretty much I could
pretend as you I would say my goodbyes
have my last night sex with her you
would because there to get it's the DNA
it's the same it's closer it's a coping
mechanism I know it's not her but I want
to pretend so that could be like can you
play this role so I could say goodbye to
you and then like rewrite history in my
brain cuz I can do that I mean I have a
romantic because I mean like I paid for
the trip
it's [ __ ] last weekend mouths no they
live there oh they live there
yeah they live in Maui they were on a
camping trip and apparently like excuse
me bless you one of the small island
everybody know everybody that's pretty
sad I'm just trying to cover my tracks
because I want to buy a farm in Maui and
I don't want them to have a grudge
against me and be like I remember you
you [ __ ]
cuz they want you to someone's gonna
link this to them so if you're watching
right now Mahalo
[Laughter]
y'all thinking to normal okay you got a
channel in what the hell would you do if
your sister or brother died in a car
crash with you and they're blaming you
but then it's like you're gonna go to
jail oh yeah then I feel so bad but then
you're going nuts cuz it's like [ __ ] man
I have it the worst cuz I just but the
murder doesn't make any sense to me
though because if it was supposed to be
a murder why would she take that [ __ ]
50/50 chance of her dying too because
they both went over yeah that doesn't
make any sense so I don't see it well
second degree murder is like if you
killed your wife because you're in the
middle of an argument but I think like
the problem that I have right now is
there's two people involved here know
that she was driving or not she could
have grabbed the wheel you know and I'll
say technically she would be the
murderer because she's the one hitting
her while she's driving so she's causing
her to go off the cliff yeah so she's
the murderer not the person driving yeah
cuz they're saying that they in
Anastasia's hands was the one that died
they found Alexandria's hair exactly so
she she would be the murderer not the
other one that she survived in general
yeah well obviously she used her sister
as a shield
poor Anastasia I feel bad for all of
them because this is a tragedy because I
know what it feels like to get in an
argument in a car and wanting to kill
and sometimes you just want to crash it
because you don't want the argument to
continue yeah but then you know what is
all this yeah dude I have never
relationship problems I never wanted to
crash a car from an argument Kasey do
the same thing you guys want to crash a
car Asian guys have anger driving right
and you're doing your thing and they're
like listen I don't want to fight it
right now and they're like no [ __ ] that
and they keep you out consulate [ __ ] I
will kill both of us right if you don't
shut the [ __ ] up yeah they just don't
give a [ __ ]
it's not know that's racist because
these twins are white but the Geils
population are they rush in because
they're kind of like the Asian Russian
whites cuz if they were Russian I'll be
like okay okay yeah I might ask you time
doing that hypothetically I would never
do such a thing
me too I'm responsible and I'm reading a
book on anger management so I think I'm
all better
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]